gender is the term that was first
introduced by John money psychologist
John money his proof of concept failed
utter miserably it could not have failed
more John money was sexually abusing
those kids and he was showing them
pornography and he was also up for
incest he was publicly pro-incest so
this is on Wicked guy when I have looked
at some of these series when I have
looked at the people who have put
forward these theories who have created
these theories there seems to be a link
between these types of theories and
pedophilia
am I wrong in making that assertion
people like John money they want to
promote the idea that we are all sexual
from Cradle to grave so if children are
sexual well then why are we preventing
them from engaging in sexual behavior
with adults I mean adults are who love
them what's wrong with that there is a
link there is a real link
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
Fascinating People our terrific guest
today is the Child and Adolescent
psychiatrist she's author of many books
the latest of which is called Lost in
Translation and you may have seen her
very important contributions to what is
a woman the documentary that we've
covered on here Dr Miriam brossen
welcome to trigonometry
well thank you so much for having me I'm
looking forward to this conversation oh
it's going to be great before we go into
the conversation itself uh tell
everybody a little bit about your
background how are you where you are
what has been the journey through life
that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us across Atlanta
well as you said I'm a Child and
Adolescent and adult psychiatrist a
medical doctor
uh let's see how did I get to be sitting
in this chair right now and talking to
you I guess the short answer would be I
always had an interest in female biology
I was always fascinated by uh the female
menstrual cycle and pregnancy and
Maternal Child bonding and uh that's
always been my first love in science now
uh I have been seeing Children and
adolescents and families for many
decades in my office
and most recently I've been seeing kids
who express some distress over being
boys or girls and their parents
now I have done a lot of research into
this field of uh let's call it gender
ideology or in my book I call it uh the
the belief system
and I have concluded that it is a
utterly unscientific uh without medical
basis uh system of beliefs that is being
uh uh thrust on us foisted on us by a a
movement a social political movement
turbocharged movement and uh the victims
here primarily are the children and
their families there are other victims
as well I believe that all of society
are victims but I'm focused since I am a
psychiatrist I'm focused on what's
happening with the children with their
parents and I am uh deeply alarmed and
angry
uh about what I've been seeing for the
past few years in my office and I felt
that a book is necessary to help these
parents they tell me that when the
announcement was made in their home Mom
Dad I'm not your son I'm your daughter
when that kind of announcement is made
they were blindsided they were shocked
they never expected it they didn't know
how to respond
and they then took their child to a
gender affirming clinic or a gender
affirming therapist and that ended up
being the worst mistake they had they
could ever have made
so uh I felt that a book is necessary
not only to help the parents that are
currently going through this crisis at
home
but in order to help parents prevent
such a crisis and so to speak to
inoculate their children and their
families from this dangerous belief
system entering and gaining a hold
with one of their kids once that happens
it can be very difficult
to get the child out
so my book is called Lost in Translation
a child psychiatrist guide
out of the madness
and I put my heart and soul into that
book I've written other books I wrote
four other books
I never put so much heart and soul into
any book as I have this book
and that is because
I have seen such such suffering
and shattered lives
uh that I decided I'm Really Gonna
devote I mean I'm at the end of my
career
but I am going to devote the years that
I have left to fighting this and so
that's how I got to be sitting in this
chair in front of you right now
that makes perfect sense mirror man it's
a real pleasure to have you on the show
and I can't wait to talk about your book
particularly uh I became a parent
recently and so I know that this is kind
of something that a lot of parents are
having to now think about unfortunately
uh but before we get to that uh one of
the things I wanted to speak with you
about we've had all sorts of people on
the show to talk about you know
whistleblowers from transgender clinics
and Physicians and parents and so on but
one thing I wanted to delve deeply into
with you first is
just some very basic questions that are
still being debated in our society
is there such a thing as gender
okay well let's see what am I gonna do
with that particular question so that
can be we can go in different directions
here okay we can talk about language
and how a uh certain lexicon that has
been created by this social movement and
this vocabulary has been uh forced upon
us
that's One Direction the other direction
we could go in is to talk about biology
so let me first go to the biology
um
let's just get certain things straight
you know from the get-go
so we are mammals
mammals are
are dimorphic in terms of their sex
there's two sex test sex has male and
female and the way that that is
determined whether a person is male or
female
is you look at their reproductive
systems and you see whether that
reproductive system is organized around
creating sperm or eggs
now it's one or the other that doesn't
mean that every single human being is
fertile there are people that are
infertile but that's besides the point
whether they are not fertile is not the
point
the point is whether the reproductive
system is fundamentally designed around
the possibility of creating eggs or
sperm
and every single human being would fall
into one of those categories
uh
well okay wait I'll wait I'm just gonna
just let me say something here and by
the way I almost chopped my finger off
yesterday in the kitchen so your
audience should just understand that's
why I have this bandage I'm fine no
worries
um there are extremely rare individuals
uh
these individuals at one time were
called hermaphrodites and they are now
called intersex
and some of those intersex people
you know a minority of them
it they may have both both male and
female elements in their reproductive
system
and I have had a patient
like that
who had both
um
uh
testicles that were undeveloped
and an undeveloped uterus
so you know and chromosomally also was
was an anomaly
so that person you could argue is is is
is truly an intersex you know un unclear
how to identify this person
but the numbers of babies being born
that fit into that category
are extraordinarily rare
and what this belief system of this
transgender belief system is foisting on
us and on children
is the belief that we all
fall within some sort of a spectrum
of male and female with male and female
only being the two extremes at each end
but then there's an infinite number of
points in between those two extremes
and we have to validate all these
possible identities
and uh that nothing is pathology nothing
is abnormal these are all variations of
human expression now to get that to your
question what is gender
gender is the term that was first
introduced
uh
in the 50s
uh by John money psychologist John money
at Johns Hopkins University
he was a famous sexologist
and psychologists whose main area of
study were these individuals that I just
described
uh intersex individuals babies
then called hermaphrodites
and his main interest was in uh how is
that assignment
made now there's the word assignment
okay that's a big word right assignment
big big word
I'll get to that in a minute
how is how are those kids assigned male
or female
when they're born
okay we're this is the 50s the 60s you
gotta wrap the baby immediately in
either a pink or or a blue blanket
we don't have those pink right now we
have
you know for a long time those those
blankets that the newborns are wrapped
in for decades now are striped blue and
pink at least in the U.S
do you have that there
no I don't think we have a specific
color but I'm sure it'll be rainbow
colors before we know it
so it used to be I mean when I was doing
my training and uh working in the
delivery room
there were pink or blue blankets and
obviously that's a very big deal what is
the very what is the first thing if you
haven't had an ultrasound and you don't
know ahead of time what is the first
thing that the doctor or Midwife is
going to say congratulations it's a boy
congratulations it's a girl
what happens if a baby is born
and they're not sure
if it's a boy or a girl so these were
the cases that John money was fascinated
with
and he proposed that
we there's he he introduced the word
gender and gender identity
to refer to our sex as separate from our
genitals so he he invented this idea
that we have a psychological sex
not just a biological sex but a
psychological sex in our mind
and that we are born gender neutral
so that when we're born even a normal
child
uh he he proposed is born without any uh
propensity or quality you know masculine
or feminine qualities yes there were
certain physical characteristics
obviously that were different
and John money would say things like
well females they lactate they
menstruate and they gestate
okay meaning they you know have their
periods their breasts produced milk and
they get pregnant and carry a child and
deliver a child but aside from those
areas
everything else is imposed by Society a
social construct
so all the sort of so-called feminine
qualities of being nurturing and you
know preferring to play with dolls
instead of uh instead of trucks and uh
interest in
uh the more nurturing professions and uh
being more uh maybe verbal and
articulate I mean all these kind of
stereotypical
uh things so John money proposed that
this is all imposed by Society
a social construct but in addition he
came up with this revolutionary theory
that because that's the case and we are
all born gender neutral that therefore a
boy could be successfully raised as a
girl
and a girl as a boy it all dependent on
environment so this was at a time in
society when there was a great debate
going on nurture versus nature
okay nurture being the our families and
our parents and siblings and teachers
and our uh all of all of the messages
that we get from our environment versus
nature what what is inborn what uh are
the role of our chromosomes the row of
our
um our biology our hormones okay nature
versus nurture
so that was a big debate at the time
now John money's theory that we are born
gender neutral
and that uh it was going to be Society
that's going to determine if a boy feels
like a boy and acts like a boy
and it was not his biology
he proposed that in order for this to
happen to raise a boy as a girl a girl
as a boy it had to happen before the age
of two and a half or three
so that was his big Theory now I'll just
throw in here and I explain this in
depth in the book
and I asked the question
when you have someone that devotes their
life to a particular cause
to promoting a certain Theory and idea
and he really did devote his life to
this idea that I just described
we have to ask why
why is that particular idea so so
important to them I'm a psychiatrist
right I'm a shrink so that's what I did
I try to figure people out
so I tried to figure out John money
why was this Theory so important to him
and as you will learn
he actually
when he did his research this experiment
on this Theory
and the results
were negative
he refused to acknowledge those results
that's how
much how important it was to him that
his theory be proven correct
and when it was proven incorrect big
time
he did not announce that he did not
acknowledge that
so why why was this so important to John
money that a person has not only a
physical sex but a psychological sex
which is their gender
and that they don't have to match
well if you look at his writings and he
wrote a lot he was prolific
um you find that John money had a very
difficult childhood
he was raised in New Zealand on a farm
and his father was a alcoholic who had
uh
who had
outbursts of rage and violence
uh and his behavior was completely
unpredictable as most alcoholics are
and little John grew up in a home in
which he was beaten by his father and he
witnessed his mother being beaten by his
father as well
now John was a uh boy who was a small a
small stature
and he was a thoughtful child and he was
not a stereotypical boy who was out
there uh getting into fights and uh
being aggressive
and
he wrote
about his childhood
that
he realized that it might be better for
women
if not only animals
but men
were gilded gel that of course meaning
castrated
um again he grew up on a farm
he saw animals being gelded I would
imagine I don't know for a fact
but he knew about gelding male animals
and he wrote that it might be better for
women and better for the world if men
were gelded the true feminist
now he also wrote and this is most
telling John money wrote
I bear the evidence of man's vile
masculinity
I don't know if I got every word there I
think that's right
something about bearing the Mark or
bearing the evidence of man's
you know a vile masculinity in other
words his genitals
so if we were to diagnose John money
today
we would say he he could have had what
we call gender dysphoria which is an
aversion a feeling of discomfort
severe discomfort with your genitals
and with your biological sex
so I'm proposing that John money had
gender dysphoria
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousand thousands of pounds
in legal fees the great thing about
expressvpn is that you don't need any
technical skills to set up just like
Francis fire up the app and it's one
button to connect One Tap on a button
was all it needed for my entire life to
disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
so gender is a concept invented by this
very troubled guy in the 50s and 60s and
yet the idea that gender exists is
everywhere now am I hearing you
correctly if we summarize that that it's
actually PS there's no such thing as
gender in humans or in animals
no I wouldn't say that because
um there are many many people that do
experience this kind of psychological
sex called gender what I would say is
the problem here is not that gender
doesn't exist it's saying that gender or
gender identity is primary is more
important than your physical identity
and that everyone has to you know bow
down and gesticulate to their own or
others perception their owner you know
perception of their gender identity that
that is primary and even if a child is
five years old
that if the moment that that boy says
I'm a girl we're supposed to all say
okay you're a girl what name do we use
what do you want to wear let's get a
let's grow your hair out and and and
imagining that they are not going to pay
a price for that for denying their
biological sex that is my argument
so what I am saying is that this idea
and it's and it is simply an idea it's
not hard science it's not something we
can measure
okay biological sex we can see it we see
it under the microscope okay you see the
chromosomes
you see the egg you see the sperm you
can measure it you can take pictures of
it you can study it using the scientific
method
gender is not something that we have we
can measure we can at least not measure
it in a way that's consistent with the
scientific method so gender would fall
into the area of soft science not hard
science
and that's important to point out as
well soft science being uh well hard
science being areas uh the study of the
of the real physical world biology
chemistry physics
[Music]
so I I just want to stop you there
because what you're saying is incredibly
interesting my question is if this man
has been discredited if his research was
found to have to to not have any
scientific value
then why is it that these ideas are
still being propagated today
bingo
and my book explains
why and the short answer is that number
one he he uh publicized his fraudulent
data
and we didn't get into the the
experiment that he did on these twins
and and we don't need to but your
audience should learn about it he had an
one experiment he did one his proof of
concept of his theory of gender identity
being uh being that we're born uh uh
gender neutral and that it's all about
society and that it's all about gender
identity and that it's flu all that
stuff
was PR his proof of concept failed utter
miserably it could not have failed more
but
it only became known that it had failed
after about
25 30 years after he began saying that
it was a success
so there was a long delay in uh the
discovery that the individuals that he
had experimented on the boy that was
raised as a girl because he had had his
penis burnt off during a circumcision
and his parents took him to Johns
Hopkins to see Dr money Dr money said
raise this boy as a girl and he will be
fine we'll castrate him we'll do some
surgery we'll give him some hormones at
the right time he'll be absolutely fine
they listened to him they tried it it
was a disaster he ended up killing
himself
he never felt like a girl he never acted
like a girl and his biology was coming
through loud and clear
that Y chromosome that tiny little Y
chromosome makes a big difference
now
by the time that David reamer this boy
that was raised as a girl
came out publicly and said my life was a
disaster because of John money
I was exploited by the medical field and
not only that but John money's results
when John money went and said that I
speaking in other words David's speaking
now that I was a success and that I
actually felt like a girl
this you know you have to understand I
mean it's it's impossible to believe
here isn't it you see David reamer was
was the perfect perfect uh
uh subject for for John money he was a
twin he had an identical twin so he and
they were of course raised in the same
environment the same family this was the
perfect setup it was the answer to John
money's prayers
and so they do this experiment and this
little boy is told from the age of about
18 months that he's a girl
okay he's still in diapers
and he's told he's a girl he's given the
name Brenda he's put in dresses uh the
whole world all his relatives and this
is the perfect
social trans we would call it socially
transitioning right now except that the
kid himself didn't know that he was
being socially transitioned
so what could be more perfect than that
and it and it was a complete failure but
Baron so that being the case why is it
Miriam that we've now seen we're fast
forward to 2023 and it feels that this
ideology is everywhere it's exploded in
popularity it's now being regurgitated
as fact why is that
well the ideologues on the left
uh took hold of what Dr money was saying
uh we're talking about the 70s the 80s
the 90s
before David Riemer came out
the book that really publicized well
there was a BBC documentary about him as
well
but this all happened in the late 90s
the book that came out published telling
his story
is called as nature made him by John
colopinto came out in 1999.
it was before John money died
John money his whole life never made any
public statements regarding what
happened in other words public
statements acknowledging the disaster of
his experiment
you're asking the question that I've
been asking for 15 years
why is it that now that we know what
happened to those twins
and did I say they both committed
suicide or did I just say David
they both commit well the other his
identical twin uh died of a of an
overdose
so he destroyed a family John money and
he was every time the kids were taken
down to see him because they lived in uh
Canada and the parents would take them
down once a year to see John money John
money was sexually abusing those kids
and he was showing them pornography
uh he in his mind well he was
pro-pornography he he felt that that
kids needed to see in order to develop
normally in terms of their sexuality he
believed that uh all children needed to
be exposed to graphic sexual images and
he was also up for incest he was
publicly pro-incest so this is a wicked
guy
I think the thing that Francis is trying
to get at is how does this person remain
in all our lives to this day with his
crazy theories uh that are now being
taught in school that are now creating
clinics I mean why is this continuing
and and your profession you're you are
is to my understanding at least a bit of
an outlier many people in your
profession believe that children who say
that they're the opposite sex must be
affirmed uh of course well that's that's
what I'm of course that's what my
Association tells me to do as well my
professional association obviously so do
they not know about John money's failed
experiment do they not care I mean how
are we here
I would say they don't know
I would say that this is already so
ingrained this whole hoax
uh has become so ingrained and baked
into
so many institutions
that it's it's it's really uh difficult
to make any sort of Headway
and make a U-turn and and look at this
and I'll tell you something also that's
very fascinating
the book that I am telling you the the
book from which I learned all this John
colapentos as nature made him
that book got an award
from an LGBT uh literary Association
like what
why why
let me explain
you see the way that they see this case
of the twins
is that this is how it's they spin it
they say well David riemer's gender
identity
was male
and
it was put upon him
that he should be female
and so that's an example
of how gender identity
is primary
so they don't say biology
they say it's his gender identity and
the poor boy his parents and everybody
was trying to tell him that he's a girl
but he knew his psych his psychological
sex was that he was a boy
and Miriam
we've now like I said fast forwarded to
2023 this thing has ex exploded more and
more children are identifying as as the
opposite sex
in your opinion
how have we got to this point it's
spreading a theory but there's something
far deeper going on societally isn't
there
well of course and I do explain just as
a continuation of your last question of
how did this happen once we knew about
David Riemer and about John money's
fraudulent research
you see yeah I explain in my book how
slowly Through The Years this idea of
gender identity being being primary more
important than biology uh that sex is on
a spectrum that you know gender and sex
started to be used as synonyms that was
a very important thing that happened but
I I focus especially on what happened in
psychiatry
okay because really I mean we're the P
we we're the ones that come out and say
what's a disorder and what is not
and we're the ones that every 10 or 15
years comes out with a new manual uh you
know the DSM uh we're now up to DSM-5
which was written in 2013.
and so it's on our shoulders right
psychiatrists and psychologists get
together talk look at the research well
they're supposed to look at the research
and make a decision about what's going
to be a disorder and what isn't
so what happened regarding this
particular situation
is that we we knew in Psychiatry for a
long long time
that there were extremely rare
individuals that had gender dysphoria
which is as an intense discomfort with
your sex
um and we knew that they basically fell
into two categories I'm oversimplifying
but let's say two categories one were
little boys who at the age of two or
three or four
when come to their parents and say I'm
not a boy I'm a girl you know I I
desperately you know I want to grow a
penis things like that and we know that
those kids if they are watched carefully
and given support the vast majority of
them if they go through puberty normal
puberty not synthetic puberty will
outgrow their gender dysphoria the other
group of people that we always knew
about were middle-aged heterosexual men
who enjoyed cross-dressing and after
having families would sometimes make the
decision to to live the rest of their
lives as a female and perhaps get the
medical treatment so those were the two
groups
now uh very rare again so what happened
is that uh when it came time okay so
there was a diagnosis in the DSM called
gender identity disorder and what I just
described to you about those two groups
they they had gender identity disorder
with the emphasis on disorder now
um Society was changing culture was
changing and there were you know in the
universities and in sex education big
big thing I I'm not going to have time
to talk to you about sex education but
yeah this was a major major influence
and pipeline in into these kids Minds
so
um all these changes were happening and
essentially they were you know it
without Psychiatry even putting their
stamp of approval on the idea that that
gender identity is more important than
biology and that you can have an
identity separate from your biology at
odds with your biology and that that is
not pathology that is not represent
Psychopathology that idea was already
swirling around and was actually
accepted I went to a lecture I think it
was in 2006.
and a psychiatrist
was it a psychiatrist it was a medical
doctor stood up and um
gave a lecture on if you have someone
that comes to your office and wants to
go on on hormones and get surgeries in
order to live as the opposite sex our
job as doctors is to give it to them
our job as doctors is not to you know
examine or do what they call gatekeeping
you know send the CH send the person for
Psychotherapy
um our job is to accept what they're
saying and to rubber stamp their
diagnosis and and do what they wish now
that was back in 2006. so and I explain
all this in the book so this was already
happening and there were a lot of people
in Psychiatry and in Psychology who
believed that we should Simply Be rubber
stamping and and and what they wouldn't
call a rubber stamping they would say
that it's the person's civil right and
that this is respecting them and
respecting their identity
and so by the time that it came to be
um for for psychiatrists to and
psychologists to to write a new DSM the
pressure was very very high not only to
eliminate this diagnosis as a disorder
but to take it out all together
so it just it shouldn't even be part of
this uh Manual of of psychiatric
disorders or conditions this is why I
asked you uh right at the beginning
about the concept of gender itself
because and I'm not a psychiatrist as
you can imagine so correct me on
everything I'm saying but it seems to me
as we've looked at this issue and talked
to different people that a lot of the
the conversation we're having stems from
the invention of this concept of gender
and if we were to say yes some people
feel a discomfort with the biological
sex that they are and yes that is
something that that causes them distress
that is something that they can seek
psychiatric help for and maybe for some
of those people living as the opposite
sex may be the right solution but that
does not mean that this mythical concept
of gender identity exists is isn't why
can't we say that because you said to me
you don't agree with that earlier why
can't we say that is it incorrect
um well listen
the questions can't even be asked
because there is a tyranny in the
organizations now
but I'm asking you I'm asking you oh
well of course that is the of course
what you just said is is correct that we
have to acknowledge that there are rare
people they used to be rare
um that do have this disorder and they
deserve our compassion and they deserve
our understanding and yes some of them
yes some of them do require these
interventions absolutely they do I'm not
denying that what I am saying is that
what we are now doing is that uh
teaching preschoolers three-year-olds
that they may have been born in the
wrong body and that that's perfectly
normal and that if they uh you know and
that if they wish to uh you know live as
the opposite sex and they wish they they
would rather be boys or they like you
know you get to pick and whatever you
pick we're going with it all the adults
are going I mean you know this is just
you know it it it's just appalling it's
astonishing it's I don't I don't know
that I have the right words to express
how destructive this is and
destabilizing to a little child to
introduce in their minds the idea that
they may be in the wrong body that is
destabilizing that is disruptive we
don't want any child to to feel uh
disembodied to feel like like
something's wrong about how they were
made this is destabilizing this is awful
this is not what we should be doing for
our children but let me just add I'm
sorry I didn't finish with the DSM so
there were people that felt it needed to
be completely removed so why did it why
was it kept in and I'll explain why it
was kept in
it was for two reasons
it was kept in because the doctors who
were involved
were compa were were compassionate and
they they felt badly
they they felt empathy for their
patients and for these individuals who
have difficult lives
and there is stigma against them and
they felt that by making this taking out
the disorder category
and no longer calling it a disorder but
emphasizing instead of the identity part
of it the incongruence of the identity
they are emphasizing the distress that
they feel
so they shifted the focus
absolutely and I look and from on on the
one hand I'm listening to this and I'm
going that is compassion and empathetic
on the other hand that is a fundamental
denial of reality in biology
and at some point
the medical industry the psychiatric
industry they're going to face a Day of
Reckoning aren't they Miriam because to
be brutally honest
there's a lot of young people and
children who have had medical
interventions
that are irreversible and highly
damaging and which they shouldn't have
had
well that Day of Reckoning it it you
know the lawsuits uh have started uh you
had the cast report uh uh and and the
and the closing the imminent closing of
Tavistock the GID service so the Day of
Reckoning uh in the U.S is certainly
coming
and I have to say I look forward to it
I've been waiting for it for a long time
I want to add one thing just because I
want to be thorough the other reason
that the diagnosis was kept in the DSM
was in order for it to have a code for
insurance purposes because these
individuals of course need uh
psychiatric help and psychological help
and some of them are going to go for the
medical interventions you need to have a
code for the insurance to reimburse you
and so Miriam what we've done is we've
identified the two groups that
historically transitioned which is the
young children and we're talking about
the adult males adult heterosexual
mouths what we haven't addressed is the
young girls which now seems to be almost
the majority of people in your opinion
what is is happening there and why
so we have a new group a new demographic
as you mentioned mostly girls still a
lot of boys it's not like it's 90 10.
it's more like maybe 60 40. there's
still an awful lot of boys
um
so this new group you know was only
recently identified in 2018 we had Lisa
Littman uh do the research and and coin
the term rapid onset gender dysphoria
and very it turned into a controversial
term and there was you know a lot of you
know
it's just it's just unbelievable what's
going on the the resistance on on the
left to fight any any shred of evidence
that their theories and their uh beliefs
about how how to treat these kids is
wrong but anyway to answer your question
this is a group of a majority
being young girls
who who never before expressed any
discomfort with being a girl
uh and who over a short period of time
and following immersion in in the
internet and uh social media
and most of them also have uh a lot of
at least one or multiple
pre-existing psychiatric problems
so by that I mean a lot of them are on
the autism spectrum they have anxiety
disorders they have social phobia
depression they may have uh self-injury
they may be cutting themselves they may
uh have undergone or gone through some
trauma in their life
and so these are girls and and I'm not
going to say just girls because there's
a lot of people actually dismiss the
boys and I'm not going to do that I've
seen too many boys in my office and talk
to too many parents of boys to do that
there's a ton of boys that are in this
also so
they are led to believe that uh that
that if they don't feel comfortable with
themselves if they don't like getting
their periods they don't fit in with
their friends they're not stereotypical
girls they're perhaps they're attracted
romantically to other girls there's many
different things that could be going on
here
well then you you might be a boy
and of course you get a lot of
um points your status is elevated when
you come out as non-male or female I
don't use the word cisgender because
that's part of the Lexicon that I refuse
to use
um if you come out to your friends uh as
being neither male or female it's you
know you're kind of an elevated status
and not only that but you are no longer
you see if you are a white heterosexual
middle class or upper class uh
student
you're an oppressor I mean that's this
is a whole other subject right
one with which we're quite familiar
believe me okay
so you don't want to be an oppressor
yeah you want to be oppressed you don't
want to be an oppressor
so if you are a member of a sexual
minority and you know or another
minority you can't change your race you
can't change your socioeconomic status
you can't change you know you're not
going to come out and say you're gay or
lesbian if you're not
but to say that you're neither male or
female okay I mean after all you know
we're all mosaics this is me speaking
now this is the truth I'm not saying
that this is what these kids say
you know I could wake up one day and be
feeling more I don't know ambitious and
aggressive and like I'm gonna go and do
this and that I could say oh I'm I'm
feeling masculine today
maybe
I'm non-binary
I mean that is why that was my first
thought when you joined the call Mary
yeah uh but listen uh I want to uh ask
you about obviously what you're saying
makes a lot of sense to us
um
how have your views been received by
your colleagues and how have you found
speaking about these issues
which you did actually much earlier than
most people from 2009 onwards what
impact has that had how easy it has it
been to publish your books Etc
uh
it's not been hard to publish my books
but I do have one of those Publishers
that
uh believe in free speech
so you've got a choice of two yeah
and my the book uh you're teaching my
child what that it that warned parents
about sex education
and I just want to emphasize you know I
write these books as a medical
professional
so my books provide science they provide
medical information this isn't you know
my beliefs as a religious person which I
am
these are medical facts
um and so you're asking about the
response
well
my 2009 book
um
was considered of course Politically
Incorrect
and so it was only uh picked up by uh
organizations that are
conservatives uh you know
religious organizations
um and so on so I mean I did have some
success not anywhere near as
what I what I still believe it deserved
the book is coming out again actually
the part it's very interesting that now
that I have this book coming out and now
that sex education finally finally
people are realizing that what their
kids are being told is just uh uh
it's wicked again we get that word back
again
I mean what we're exposing kids to at a
young age and the lies that we are
telling them not only about gender about
other things but finally people are
waking up and parents are waking up I
hope in the I know in the U.S I don't
know about the UK
oh by the way did you know that I spoke
in the House of Lords 11 12 years ago no
we didn't no we didn't no you don't how
would you know yeah there's a reason why
they left dislike you Miriam right so I
spoke there about sex education and oh
boy at that time your sex education in
the UK it was even worse than ours
when I say worse than ours if I recall
correctly you had websites I'm getting
off topic a little bit but I remember
doing research into your sexuality
education there and going on to
government websites uh you know or ngos
you know NGO organizations that are
funded by your government and there
would be links provided to the kids that
were on that site of where to go like
bars where to go for gay sex
it just I mean
yeah I I just yeah I I mean whenever we
touch upon this subject it I I find it
horrifying particularly as I you know I
used to be a teacher and an education
I guess the question and the reason I
stopped you though is because I'm going
to ask a question which
is an uncomfortable one but I know but I
didn't answer wait do you want
but not big because it provides a link
into the question that I'm gonna ask
which I really which I think goes to the
heart of some of this stuff when I have
looked at some of these series when I
have looked at the
people who have put forward these
theories who have created these theories
there always seems to be a link and if
I'm wrong please push back on me I'm not
putting words in your mouth there seems
to be a link between these types of
theories and pedophilia
am I wrong in making that assertion
or is there truth to what I'm saying and
why is it that we are not actually
shouting about this from the rooftops
because it is a child protection issue
some people are shouting from the
rooftops as usual they're they're being
silenced and not given the microphone
uh
I would say that I I call what's going
on with kids grooming
okay so let's define what grooming is
grooming is the emotional and
psychological manipulation of a
vulnerable person with the goal of
exploiting them in some way in the
future
there is sexual grooming there is
financial grooming
and there is ideological grooming
now I believe that with all of our
sexuality education and gender education
there is no doubt in my mind that there
is sexual and ideological grooming
that's going on
and I'll explain a very simple thing to
you
you see if you have a four or
five-year-old
uh and they're in a preschool group
and the page and the um the teacher
begins to discuss
um
uh anatomically correct names for the
body
and this is a this is a huge thing you
know in in sex education that these
little kids need to know
uh penis and vulva and clitoris and
testicles like they all need to know
they shouldn't be using childish names
for those parts of their bodies oh no no
no no no that's a bad thing they need to
know the the terms the actual terms
but you see when that's begins
what happens
the message that the child is given a
is that
we can talk about these very private
things
at school
we should not feel a sense of
embarrassment if we feel a drop of
embarrassment we need to deny that
the teachers talking about these things
she or he feels very comfortable talking
about a penis and a vulva and a clitoris
I should also be comfortable with all my
classmates around me boys girls with
this teacher that I may have just met
two weeks ago
I'm supposed to feel comfortable
so that's called desensitization
and that is
the beginning of Grooming
because in order to groom somebody that
person has to feel comfortable with you
and has to trust you
so when our sex educators are telling us
as they have been for so long
that these little kids need to learn
they're anatomically correct words for
their bodies and I'm that's only the
beginning I mean they're telling them
about
uh you know anal sex by the time they're
10 years old but let's put that aside
so it's a form of Grooming
um it's a form of at such a young age
the child is supposed to deny their
inborn sense of
shame or embed let's say embarrassment
that's a normal sense of embarrassment
that should be there
that's what I'm arguing we want our kids
to have that
and the other message that the kids get
from the teacher from that whole thing
of being of teach of learning those
words and talking about genitals
is they get the message that it's not at
home that I'm going to learn about these
things it's not my parents that are the
experts that I need to go to for my
questions it's my school it's my teacher
it's people outside
and it's it's a good point and I take
your point but let's just go back to my
initial question about the the you know
we've brought up your money I've read
and I've heard about other people who
have propagated these theories and again
there was the issue of oh I'll tell you
well I'm gonna try it in okay when a
child
has has internalized that message of I
can trust this person this adult
um I it's not at home that we discuss
these issues I have to
um I I have to deny my internal
discomfort that is is group is making
that child more available for
inappropriate sexual behavior
that's how I'm tying this into the
pedophilia does that work for you
yes but I I'm I mean it does and I get
what you're saying and it's a very good
point but I was looking at it more most
in the case of if we look back at it
historically a lot of people who have
propagated and created these theories
there is a link is there not or am I
um are my misrepresenting or simply
incorrect yeah there is a link and
there's the the link is to uh uh destroy
any uh any remnant of any
judeo-christian morality in our society
and that's a part of it
um you know the sexual morality part of
it and and again people like John money
uh uh Alfred Kinsey that who we didn't
discuss They promoted also a pedophile
they want to promote the idea that we
are all sexual from Cradle to grave so
if children are sexual well then why are
we preventing them from engaging in
sexual behavior as adults I mean adults
are who love them what's wrong with that
so it's all part of destroying the
morality that so yes I agree with you
there is a link there is a real link
uh Miriam we're running out of time I
know that one of the things you're Keen
to get across in your latest book is and
we've had people who de-transitioned and
people who nearly transition and parents
who socially transition their children
on the show but one of the things you
really wanted to talk about is and
briefly is the impact that gender
ideology and its consequences has on the
entire family unit not just the
individual young person who goes through
this so correct tell us in a couple of
minutes
what's going on there okay okay I mean
I'll just emphasize that my book Lost in
Translation is a book for families for
parents it is not for professionals it's
for moms and dads to be able to
inoculate their families against these
dangerous ideas before they have a
problem
before one of their children comes home
and says Mom Dad I'm not your son I'm
your daughter so it's very practical
advice I have conversation I have model
conversations that you can have with
your child a model conversation you can
have with a therapist or the principal
of your school
now the impact what you just asked me
the impact on families
you know we're all focused on the young
people of of course we are of course
we're focused on them they are the
primary that's Ground Zero
but we have to also acknowledge and what
I've seen over these years talking to
hundreds of parents
is this is this from for many parents
although I would say maybe all parents
that go through this
it is the most difficult and devastating
experience they've had in their lives
I'm talking about parents who may have
gone through cancer Financial ruin
divorce
911 what have you covid
and yet seeing their child
uh be be recruited by these by this
ideology by this belief system and to
watch what it does to their child as
their child changes before their very
eyes even even prior to any
medicalization they see their child
changing before their eyes because these
children change
and they come under the influence of
strangers
and they those strangers place a wedge
between the child and their loving and
devoted parents these are not parents
who need to be reported to child
protective services and trust me as a
child psychiatrist I myself have
reported families to Child Protective
Services in the past so I know all about
that and I know all about families that
cannot raise a child uh and the child
has to be removed for safety purposes I
know about that
these are loving and devoted families
and the child needs their parents and
their parents have the right the
constitutional right to uh to to direct
their child's uh upbringing their
education and their medical care
now these ideologues these people
at school uh uh uh pediatricians Child
Protective Services uh
well you know like you said it's
everywhere
a wedge is placed in that relationship
and sometimes it's the wedge becomes too
big and the child is actually estranged
from the family but even if the child is
not as strange the impact on the parents
I just spoke to a woman
who is going through this uh with their
their her daughter is identifying as a
boy
this woman a few decades ago in her
native country went through a genocide
she lived in a country that a few
decades ago they had a genocide
she lost her family
and a limb
one of her limbs
this woman told me that going through
what she's going through with her
daughter identifying as a boy and
wanting to go on testosterone
has shattered her life
more than the genocide did
so this is affecting
this has a ripple effect not just
parents siblings grandparents cousins uh
and we didn't even speak about the uh
you know the other students in the
classroom what's the effect on other
students in the classroom when suddenly
they come back from their summer
vacation and who they uh someone that
they always saw as a boy is now they're
supposed to in their minds think of as a
girl so we don't have time for that but
let me just remind your audience that I
am providing this is the first book in
existence written by a medical doctor
that is uh providing parents with the
information that they must have to
understand this and to uh and to prevent
to do what they can to give them the
tools to prevent this terrible
devastating damage from affecting their
families
Miriam we are going to continue the
conversation with questions from our
supporters and a few more from us on our
locals but for this section of the
interview we always end with the same
question which is what's the one thing
that you think we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be
and it doesn't have to be related to
this although I imagine it might be
we're not talking about how evil really
does exist
we have to face it if we don't face it
you know we're going to have we are
having
uh this Devastation that can have we
have to we have to acknowledge that
there are evil ideas and that there are
evil individuals
uh and
and if we don't recognize that how are
we going to fight it
well thank you for that and uh we invite
you all to join us over on locals where
we continue the conversation
is the psychiatric sanity pendulum
swinging back
or will it get worse before it gets
better
[Music]